what is
iido the name iido is pretty
straightforward iido is the way to
practice I ke this leaves us with a
burning question what is I ke many
arguments have been made to where the
term I ke comes from some say that it's
a fashionable word made up by onos
deuchi and used by Saku DEA and Mahi
yiba to name their martial arts systems
others believe that iki is an old term
that yashiba took from his teacher
sokaku DEA the term being used since
perhaps the 11th century in trying to
understand what II means to the practice
of iido we may want to look to the old
sources in order to get a handle on what
II is however it would be much more
convenient if the founder simply told us
what he meant by I ke unfortunately
exactly what the founder thought I was
can sound a bit metaphysical at times in
cas omaru yuba's book iido under the
section words of the founder yiba is
quoted as saying although the word II is
an old one the word as it was used by
the Warriors of the past is
fundamentally different than
mine from this we can realize that if we
want to understand what II meant to the
founder we don't need to look at earlier
usages of the word because he means
something different from the word than
II meant by his predecessors
yashiba then goes on further to say iido
is not a technique to fight with or
defeat the enemy it is a way to
reconcile the world and make human
beings one
family this first part is very clear as
to what he thinks II is not it's not the
same as his predecessors would use the
word this makes it clear that however
the term was used before isn't what his
system I is about the second part might
at first sound a bit
metaphysical however I believe it can be
read directly and in this video I'm
going to show you
[Music]
how how I was told ik is made when I
first started studying iido my teacher
provided a four-step process used to
make ik ke the four-step process
consisted of K masubi AAS and
zanin to put this simply the process of
making I key as I was taught consists of
composing yourself mentally physically
emotionally in order to understand
another
person then you are going to
energetically connect to that person and
empathetically understand them next
you're going to coordinate your actions
with their
actions and then you're going to stay
vigilant so that I ke doesn't fall apart
if we look at this as a way to possibly
make I ke we can start to ask what would
we make I ke for and how would that look
as students of the martial arts we might
want to say we want to use I ke to win a
fight but remember Yuba said that I ke
is not a technique to fight with or
defeat the enemy so how else could we
use this process of making I ke let me
share some work I've been doing with you
and maybe we can shed some light on what
Yuba might have meant there's a tool I
created a few years back when teaching a
self-defense class I call this tool the
ladder of relationship it's a simple
tool that gives visual aid to how
relationships become positive or
negative the first rung of this ladder
is called stranger this is where we
start with anyone when we meet them the
first time if this interaction goes well
we would move that person up to someone
we like if that goes even better and
over a period of time we might become
friends with that person after a long
relationship that person would become
someone who's like family we would say
we love them of course this latter works
the other way as well if we met someone
and didn't like them we would say we
dislike this person if they presented
themselves even worse we might say we
have contempt for them actively hoping
things go bad for them if it continues
in a negative Direction then we would
get aggressive toward them and physical
violence might even start to happen
originally I used this tool to explain
to self-defense students why
deescalation and empathetic
understanding are an important part of
self-defense recently however I put this
tool together with what I call my
spectrum of conflict and discovered an
even more powerful
tool this new chart can help us see that
when a relationship becomes emotionally
very negative it may very well become
physical the physical side of this also
having stages the first three distancing
the next three levels of connection and
the last two limiting physical
Mobility by putting these two charts
together we can get a pretty complete
picture of both the escalation and
deescalation of complex
we can see what entrenches us more
deeply in conflict and what moves us
away from
conflict we can then use this chart to
explore what martial arts systems are
trying to do what stages they work on
and whether they are moving up or down
the chart for example if we look at
Brazilian jiujitsu we can see that the
whole objective of the system is to move
down the chart the goal is to force the
conflict into later stages in order to
limit the options of the other party in
fact we will find that most systems
attempt to draw the conflict down into a
stage where they develop skills to
dominate does iido do the same thing we
could speculate that it does we could
look at the pins found at the end of the
forms and say that iido uses the same
strategy as most other systems to bring
the other party down to a place where we
can dominate them with pins and throws
I would however like to suggest a
different idea that iido is a very rare
system in that it always wants to go up
the ladder ideally solving the conflict
in the emotional stages and making a
friend out of an enemy if you think of
most martial arts systems they work by
teaching students to force the person
into an area of conflict where they are
able to easily defeat that person I'm
suggesting that iido is trying to much
more directly solve the problem by
making a friend out of a former enemy
this is why iido is not about fighting
or defeating an enemy as yashiba
consistently States but instead iido is
a process of removing yourself from
dangerous situations in order to resolve
the situation by making peace with the
opposition this represents a
revolutionary way of looking at martial
arts
systems a problem I see in working with
conflict theory today is that you don't
have any methods of bridging the gap
between emotional conflict and physical
conflict conflict resolution tends to
have two major camps of thought one is
about feelings love and joy the other is
about guns and
fists this leads us to create a false
dichotomy where believe conflict
resolution is about this or that when in
truth these two exist on the same
Continuum what if we had a martial arts
system that could bridge the gap between
those two I believe yashiba gave us
exactly that in his system of
iido of course this is all
conjecture however for me this
interpretation not only fits with
everything I've read from the founder in
his later life it also has the potential
to be a totally different kind of
martial arts system as I move forward
working on my own system this is the
route I'll be taking thank you for
listening I'm Christopher
Hine